little piece of the Dead
they're not afraid of anything
but I am Dom Toretto lives in a world
that sometimes feels relatable but the
undercurrent of that world is not his
approach to fatherhood has to account
for the world that he's been brought
into most often to save the world that
he never promised to save
we are a different family than like
families in the neighborhood
dumb knows that no matter what he will
be chased his entire life in past 10 you
will see a fatherhood that's more
representative of a fatherhood in the
past where you teach your kid to be a
Survivor I would say he's pretty tough
because he has his family around him oh
he knows that he's protected it's
like a family bond how do you choose
the ones you save it's something that
every father and mother in the world can
identify with we all want the Next
Generation to be better than the last
I'm coming for you son